>> So I'm here with Pentaho. Who are you guys
and what do guys do?
>> So, we're an open source business intelligence
company. We build applications for people
interested in doing reporting, analysis, data
integration, and data mining. And we have
a lot of thick client applications as well
as a lot of growing number of thin client
applications. Primarily, using or lately GWT
or GWT for the development of this.
>> I know that you used GWT, do you use any
other APIs? And then, what were your reasons
for using Google Web Toolkit?
>> In addition to using GWT, we also integrate
with some of the Google data APIs, including
Google Analytics, which we just now used today
and Google Docs. We're also--we were one of
the first BI companies to integrate with Google
Maps, making it easy to build location with
Dashboards within our products.
>> So, what were the reasons behind, you know,
most of the Google Wave guys which is [INDISTINCT]
>> Well, I guess, looking at it from the GWT
perspective that was something that I perceived
as, "What can I use to get something done
with the limited amount of time that I have
to do with them?" And so, I basically, went
on vacation for a week and I had a lot of
ideas for what I wanted to do and I wouldn't
advertise myself as a JavaScript to developer,
simply because I don't actually enjoy that.
I'm able to do it, but I don't necessarily
enjoy it. I wanted to get something done rather
than fight a war against Web browsers. So,
I wanted to--if it was going to be on my own
time, my own spare time, I wanted to actually
enjoy it and I wanted to get something done.
That's primarily why I chose that technology
and it was also the fact that I could use
all the Java tools that I'm already familiar
with.
>> So GWT--that's great. Do you [INDISTINCT]
and if you are familiar with the maintenance?
>> Yes.
>> Absolutely, we're--most of our products
are Java based, so it was very natural for
our teams of Java developers to migrate towards
using GWT for our clients' side, thin client
development.
>> So, did you guys encounter any difficulties
building your software with GWT? Or any, like,
interesting anecdotes from that?
>> Yeah, there's probably been plenty of those.
We have a situation--we actually have an iFrame
in our application, which displays our reports,
our content, that could be PDFs. And the different
browsers are actually handling those plug-ins
differently than others. So for example, if
we have an overlap of a menu item, it would
get clipped behind the PDF and there's a bunch
of cases where it's not necessarily the fault
of GWT, it's just the fact that we got a more
or less a native plug-in sitting on top of
there and it makes it look like it is. So,
we had some workarounds that we're able to
put in place. Probably, one of the biggest
things that always gets us is CSS--I mean,
I heard somebody talking about it in the Keynote
or something earlier today, and it really
is the thing that you can sit there and you
can assume, "Oh, you know, it's something
with GWT, you know, GWT compiler must not
have produced this correctly." And you sit
there and you want to blame it, but in the
end, you'll find a lot of times you're actually
getting a CSS issue. We had one recently where
we're getting a Scroll Bar on the right hand
side of our application. We couldn't get rid
of it and it turned out to be a CSS issue.
And it only happened in--it was either IE
or Firefox, but it was one of those things
that only happened in one browser and it was
like, "Oh, great." You know, "We finally found
the thing that GWT can't handle, but, nope,
CSS again."
>> So, it seems like you have some tips and
tricks from other developers, is there any
others you would care to share?
>> One of the areas that we've come across
is, trying to transport our Java Models and
Java Objects over to the thin client, and
one tip that I would definitely recommend,
if you are transferring those objects, be
very careful that they're all referenced directly
in your GWT and if they're referenced directly,
then make them somehow be referenced. Otherwise,
GWT RPC won't actually serialize these objects
across where it goes, and you'll get very
odd airs that aren't intuitively, obviously
RPC, you know, RPC issue, so. For instance,
we had a HashMap of objects, we were, we're
passing a lot of different types of Java objects
over the wire and all those are serializable,
but we haven't exclusively call them out in
the GWT as servlet code. So, they weren't
making their way into our GWT environment
from by, basically adding some stuffed out
method that referred to those objects it was
able to transport. That was fine.
>> So, what are the features that I missed
about [INDISTINCT]?
>> Well, as I said before one of the primary
reason that I chose it was the fact that it
has a pretty large tool set behind it because
it is Java. So, I could develop an Eclipse
and use all of the debugging and all the re-factoring
of the features that are built-in to that.
So, the fact that it's written in Java I don't
know if I would call that a feature of it,
but that's just--that is just the way it is.
But that's big enough for me that I called
it a feature. I'm a big fan of the Image Bundle
and there's a term on that. We talked about
as well.
>> GWT RPC, you know.
>> The--as I--you call it really simple RPC.
>> Yup.
>> I mean, it is, it is that. Yeah.
>> What do you think that you can improve
upon?
>> Of the what?
>> What do you think could be improved upon?
>> Improved upon, well, one thing that actually
got a lot better in I6 due to parallel compilation.
Historically our problem was waiting for it
to compile. Still an issue but depending on
how powerful our machines are with multi-course,
like our continuous integration machine has
a--it's a four core box and it sees a really
big improvement from the parallel compilation.
But there's--it's still an issue that, that
affects us. And so, I would say, okay, that's
an area that, if it can be improved on it
will be great if it was improved upon, but
I know that area is being pushed pretty hard.
>> I think it's on the list. So, would you
recommend GWT to develop these other features?
>> Yeah, yes, absolutely and that's what we
were doing today. We got a lot of folks to
come up to the GWT area asking lots of great
questions. Job developers and non-job developers
seeing a value in GWT and why, developing
and GWT can increase your velocity. And basically
make it a lot easier to develop true rich
apps that used some of these new capabilities
like Google Gears and some of this other,
richer client. I think client capabilities
with java, with the enterprise capabilities
that you get from Java.
>> Is anything else that you guys want to
pass?
>> You can check out our open source software
at Pentaho.com. We have a great community.
We have forums, IRC, lots of voice to contribute.
>> How do you spell Pentaho?
>> Pentaho, is P-E-E-N-T-A-H-O.com. Okay.
>> Great. Thank you guys for coming out here
at I/O.
>> Thank you.
>> Great.